I'm telling you dummy The
Inquisitor is Ezra Miller
that's a theory I can get behind that makes
way more sense that The Inquisitor is Ezra
Bridger it's not Ezra it's obviously Barris
it's not and I don't know why you Champion
for Qui-Gon Jinn listen like guys we
gotta do the little we're gonna watch
Soca episode three today people so use the force
to leave a like I guess follow MJ Tesla Star
Wars nerd on Instagram if you want but guys
I'm also on X hey I'm trying to transition
to our sponsor greetings fellow questers prepare
to embark on a magical journey with Omni Heroes
the ultimate blend of heroic fantasy and strategy
RPG Envision a world where Valkyries our Beacon
of light aren't snared by treacherous demons your
quest should you choose to accept it morph into
a nominee Guardian Unleash Your Inner hero and
save those ethereal maidens from the clutches
of darkness two of our legendary lasses stealing
the spotlight dorabella with spell so cool they're
downright enchanting Andy lular who's more than
just Athena's Shadow she's a blazing Legend but
wait there's more lore in store how many Heroes
isn't just about brandishing swords and fleeing
spells it boasts a Synergy system remix over 100
Heroes to devise unbeatable team combos conquer
Realms and reign supreme and adrenaline pack PVE
and PVP battles weave your strategies Flex those
magical muscles and Ascend the global Throne
weary from your request fret not Embrace The
Game's Idol charms or with a mere wizardly wave or
tap because you know phone Watcher power soar from
joining Mystic guilts and navigating enchanting
labyrinths and trying your luck in blackjack
challenges that's a roller coaster of runes and
riches radio Summers magic download and install
Omni Heroes now for a whoppy 777 free summons
secure minimum of five Legendary Heroes ensuring
an epic start Omni Heroes is now available on
both the Apple App Store and Google Play Store
and has earned recommendations from Google Play
chillax or strategize with enchanting Valkyries
so brave adventurers are you game leave it on me
Heroes whatever we spell slash and Synergy counts
fret full-length Reaction watch along where
you sync it with your own copy it was so good
available for super section we took at our
favorite sport to really watch the episode
oh oh the Sabers now was that Rex I'd
kill for Live Action wrecks I think
we'll get him in this show if it's
gonna happen it has to happen here
it's like that Demon Slayer episode
oh sweet all the different lightsaber forms
this is exciting
oh oh it's like training if I Grievous oh no I'm
not certain lady Ren is ready for that technique
shut up huying your skill with a weapon
comes from your Mandalorian upbringing
those skills alone will not be
enough to defeat our enemy Kane
also helped learning to wield the
force takes a deeper commitment
Force sensitive by the end of this and I'm
going to be like hot everyone who gave me
crap about it here this on we're gonna do
the classic you're nothing but potential kid
you're joking you've literally seen
Ezra do this before you've got this
uh sick old Jedi symbol I want you to see with
more than just your eyes feel the road Ricky
Bobby do you know where I am next to who Yang are
you sure how'd she project her voice like that
Juilliard she can throw her voice it's a lot
of drama school taken all that is around you
I love the mood of this I love
my voice oh Yang's falling asleep
I love this
and the sound design to the
surround classic martial arts
movie we're gonna say it's tefloni's favorite
even the sword designs are just
wonderful I feel like Kendo swords right
got one
oh very good Sabine very bad to me
don't let your rage get ahead of you
use the foals she can't she never will Michael
because she chooses not to oh she sensed it
sweep the lake anger and frustration are quick
to give power yeah but they also imbalance you
I'm not a balance you're on balance this is a
good throwback to tales of the Jedi when Anakin
was teaching Ahsoka how to handle it really good
call yeah or it's just a classic trope eight wings
also we totally missed home one oh one there it is
the chancellor she's waiting oh
yes has she aged you look well
how's young Jason oh Jason finally
got mentioned in fact he's on board
somewhere oh he's there somewhere trouble
with chopper have you thought about Kaden
at all I was attacked by Imperial loyalists
still working for Morgan ellisbeth outliers
former Imperials working throughout every level of
the new republic government have all taken an oath
of loyalty except those ones long live the Empire
doesn't sound like the kind of loyalty we're
looking for but I believe their activity speaks
to a larger operation involving thrawn thrawn
isn't this just another attempt
to gain New Republic resources to
Aid in what has ultimately been
your personal quest to find Ezra
Bridger is there something wrong with
that were you ever in the war senator
no just sat back and waited to see who
came out on top are you a [__] senator
where those balls that I do the Imperial
Fleet is scattered and broken they have
no centralized command unless I've seen the
Mandalorian Famous Last Words thrawn is not
your typical Imperial officer no he's
not I know because I fought against him
he's nuanced some people argue
that he's a good guy bran Admiral
for a friend Ezra Bridger heroically
died with him you don't know that
he's getting a rise out of her I will say
they've done a great job at making me happy that
Starkiller base blew up the new Republic with all
of her interactions with their government so far
Jason oh he's less colorful he's gonna be a Jedi
he definitely got the human genes it's okay his
hair is a little green I want to be a Jedi he said
he wants to be a Jedi the music oh he definitely
wants to be more like his dad I was hoping that
the urgency of our situation could expedite my
training a bit you don't get like a certificate
Sabine you're not Luke Skywalker traffic school
I can't use a force I don't feel it not like
you do sake bomb Force resides in all living
things even you so this is a you problem if that's
true then why doesn't everyone use it Talent is a
factor and mediclaureates training and focus are
what truly defines someone's success amen sister
yes start small I want to be able to not lean
for my drink I'm going to give this my best
why did she decide to train her though you know
like what was it about her that she was like I'm
going to try I want to know that specifically what
went down there I hope that we go back a little
bit but I feel like part of it's a debt to both
Kanan and Ezra you both knew this wouldn't be easy
well what you said didn't help Jedi Order
would not have accepted her she is not an
acceptable candidate I only speak the truth
standards which were proven over a millennia
and failed yeah times have changed I don't need
Sabine to be a Jedi I need her to be herself
you do come from a long line of non-traditional
Jedi that way she fits right in Yoda to Count
Dooku Count Dooku to Qui-Gon Qui-Gon to Obi-Wan
Obi-Wan Anakin Anakin to Ahsoka and Ahsoka does
it mean very impressive Michael I'm very proud of
you well done I can name all the presidents too
it's a little nudge
you can't force the force
she could she did that Sabine did that I
heard you telepathically you win this round
watch it moved by itself it walks away I won't be
joining you for this one and neither
will the fleet what that's Bull fleet
era the Yang what's happened she was better at
politics all cotton Transmissions are
being jammed oh someone's undertale
space so far from the planet standard Jedi
Mission protocol When approaching an unknown
situation we park down the street whatever
it is has a signature which is unknown to me
so much unknown stuff in this not for a long what
do we got here oh man this look like bad guys
the Squadron of World War II fighter pilot
as well it kind of remind me of like uh on it
nice oh we're getting New
Hope references I feel it
so you got rid of my presets
two and three close range and
engage can never understand
why like high value Forest wielding
individuals would risk flying in ships
again remember learn to anticipate now's
not the time for a lesson yeah it's
always a time for a lesson oh yeah
come on Sabine just get one
I have several thoughts on
everything else okay not now
the way you're those actions
I love that look that she gave who Yang was right
get into the zone
I love it
all right ready I love the processing of
emotions that you could feel on Rosario Dawson's
I love you now just get one
all right let's go let's go
do a barrel roll
I have two more incoming I love how this
is just becoming a full-on training session
get one come on yeah
yeah
let's roll them copy that her tendrils have
so much movement they did such a good job
they shouldn't stare at somebody's
tendrils they called leku
there's a well-crafted sequence
oh boy yeah it's like a hyperspace Drive yeah just
some sort of hyperspace ring I'd like to confirm
excellent
Morgan are you gonna fly
into it prepare turbo lasers
turbo base well if you play empire
thanks for talking over it it's a kylo ren
mask if you're not going to hear they're
real there's an obvious clue that it was Ezra he
literally said I Ezra Bridger agreed to the plan
I got Green Lasers
Dre uses sound design
this is beautiful I'm excited to get
this track in Star Tours coming up
I'm excellent piloting yeah so cantankerous
Don't Look So Satisfied yeah she seems so happy
foreign
destroyed nice Cut series over
and we will have a three episode in
memoriam oh it's an unsettling shot
get on it gotta put on your own oxygen mask first
[__] um we'll take it from here I like
this little rivalry it's an uneasy Alliance
out there out there just keep
working any fighter I'm gonna
pull a layer yeah just Mary Poppins that [__]
she is a captivating performer she does
a lot with a little I think the villains
this is the best villains we've had oh
my God yes whoa okay yes this is what
I'm talking about let's go especially
than a helmet especially super perfect
oh my God
this is really cool that's really inventive
did you fix the ship yet
it's awesome awesome shots Jeepers
wow that was really well orchestrated
nice trick oh my god get me a Funko figure
of this oh it's happening on good time
this is a genuinely exciting aerial sequence
yeah feels like a good cross between Star Wars
and like an actual World War II kind of thing I
mean that's how we made all the original scenes
oh my God damn oh [__]
she has her on top of it
and Paula tradies online
oh the scope and scale of them oh I'm
loving the perspective it's extraordinary
geez go in the mouse ever seen
Pinocchio monster all this [__]
oh hell yeah hey Cthulhu
it could be Starkiller
again those locked off shots
this is a [__] blast I mean how do you make a
unique new type of Star Wars space Chase sequence
where
are they
complete we almost died multiple times
oh yes standard operating procedure sir
I appreciate the Old Republic symbol
or you go with wings there shut the power down
your Jedi protocol I suppose that's true it's true
good news attention here how does the ring
work in conjunction with the Pergo that they'd
like force it to go through that of specific
ringers yeah or maybe there's something about
this planet being like the per girls home
that you think this planet is specifically
their home or they just like camped out here
right it's interesting that they're like in
the lower atmosphere of the planet haven't seen
those creatures since the day Esra disappeared
there are six hyperdrive engines in place
with the final one being set into position
okay but I have never seen one built on
this scale before Intergalactic travel
you can't get a ring like that make a jump
to a neighboring Galaxy archive speak of
Intergalactic hyperspace Lanes between galaxies
which used to follow the migration Paths of star
whales named perkel oh there we go like the
ones we just saw yeah really wait a minute
you never believe such a
healthy amount of exposition ah
hunt them down oh boy
he's so good I can't wait
for him in Ahsoka to fight
not even just standing there he just
has tons it's just such a good villain
oh man I was really enjoying that yeah
ah too short that was way too short too
short but definitely leaves you wanting more
yeah in a good way yeah oh we're on the right
track chit chat I mean it's pretty obvious
that they're setting up Jason for a future
spin-off show or he's Gonna Wanna become
a Jedi guys that's my big takeaway out of
everything happened in this episode I got one
take away yeah setting up the New Canaan show
and they can make their own like Young Avengers
get grogu yellow Jason come on you know they're
gonna do more children well you know he
could end up at the Jedi Temple and you
know everything goes right what happens
this is what happens that's what happens
uh the history repeats that'd be great
maybe get a fun side of Kyla yeah I the
more kylo friend Kyla friend it would be fun to
depending on how this pans out to have a large
group of characters end up in this other Galaxy
permanently as to explain their absence in the
sequel Trilogy yeah because I that's gonna bug me
yeah forever big time the only issue is the ghost
uh Hera's ship is in the sequel Trilogy yeah it's
at the Battle of Mexico um I overall really like
this episode a lot uh I had a lot of fun with
this one and it was it felt it had that actual
that's spirit that that genuine spirit and wonder
of what I thought Mandalorian season three was
often kind of like fail at and feel rushed during
yeah this didn't do that yes it's a short episode
uh but still I felt the substance of it and I I
genuinely had a really good time am I like on the
edge of my seed in terms of like suspense no but
in terms of absorbing the adventure I really feel
the absorption of that and I'm I'm really finding
myself much more endeared now because the last the
last two you know had a more serious tone which
is not a problem to me at all like I I overall
I loved it uh while I had a little bit of gripes
in terms of so and I know some people have a push
back on this I feel like there's a divide here
I've noticed some people have echoed our opinions
of some of that stoism that I was like I could use
a little bit just more pep in the personality in
some way and and I thought this really brought it
with with Ahsoka and Sabine and the chemistry like
I really felt the chemistry between them
this time yeah and I found myself really
um enjoying the whole training segments with them
especially at the very top of this episode and
then watching as Ahsoka again being the the master
learning from your Padawan similar to like how
like you know Ahsoka was paired up with Anakin so
Anakin could learn something about himself as well
and now you're watching that trajectory um unfold
and while like that's part of the package usually
with Master battle one it this really feels
like okay specifically with Anakin to Ahsoka
and now for Ahsoka to Sabine it is so is just as
much about the master learning about themselves
and how to be uh as well as the Padawan on top of
that too so I really I really like this one a lot
I like the future of where it's headed towards and
when they finally reveal that that was Ezra under
the mask the whole time it's nice to see Ahsoka
because I I was doing a lot of thing about it
um you know and I think everybody in the
comments section agreed like Silk is like a very
uptight but not the traditional friendly happy
vibrant Ahsoka that we knew in in the early
seasons of The Clone Wars and you know you can
only imagine the trauma that it is of having
somebody that you're so close with that you know
on such a personal deep intimate level only for
them to fall the way that Anakin did and I think
something that we're going to continue to explore
is between the relationship between Ahsoka
and Sabine part of the reason that Ahsoka
is struggling to be a real master is
because that level of being vulnerable
is something that I I think she's scared to get
hurt again and it's not that she doesn't care
about Sabine it's just that it's you know what if
I do this wrong and and yeah you know my Padawan
goes to the dark side well then yeah the last time
between Rebels to Mandalorian the last time we saw
Ahsoka uh in the animated format other than the
ending T's the Cliffhanger was that she just got
the revelation of Anakin as Darth Vader yeah and
you can only imagine the uh emotional trauma and
put through space and time missed several years
of her life some trauma it makes sense to me I
think some people misunderstand if I say like
I don't think stoic is is necessarily bad yeah
and I think that there is there's kind of like
a multi-layer that I was sort of craving I guess
is what more because I'm like no it makes sense
to me that she would be different yeah based off
of what she went through like of course she would
be different and we're starting to see those the
dimensions of the relationship yeah and the Nuance
of it and I really appreciate what you said about
that because I think we're we're gonna continue
to see that evolution I'm glad that Hera and I
can't believe I'm saying this isn't coming along
for this leg of the journey if only to give those
to the room for their relationship to really
having just them if only for an episode or two
is really really important to that relationship
developing in a big way um I did want to say that
uh I felt like Hera's portrayal um number one
I think uh on an acting level doing an amazing
job I just remember her being so much better at
politics though like that was something that was
uh when we see her Evolution as like the leader
of you know Phoenix Squadron and the rebel cell
and then the introduction to the larger Rebel
organization I feel like she was so good at
navigating the nuance and the politics of it all
only to just like not necessarily be on her game
um and part of me wonders if that you know is an
intentional trying to show that you know in the
absence of of of Canaan in the absence of you know
the family that she's built um that she's kind of
pulling at strings for you know what she Longs for
and misses um but I thought that Dynamic is really
interesting the new Republic I just I I think
they need to do something to make me care about it
um and they haven't need to do something to to
give the new Republic like a POV or something
more than them just going it's fine we're the
new Republic and that's it some kind of I think
in the same way that like Mon mothma and Andor
did like such a good job at making the Rebellion
feel more Dynamic and interesting I'm not saying
like I want like a political thriller but I want
to show that not every single person in the new
republic government is an absolute idiot right
um because right now it's being set up is that and
it's just it's been consistently unrewarding uh
time and time again where it's like wow these are
just a bunch of bureaucratic idiots um which makes
everything that was fought for feel so that yeah
like like what about all the often spies that died
to get them that information but well yeah I mean
I guess the part of it that lacks a believability
area because like yeah I get the whole turn in
The Blind Eye thing a history repeating itself
and whatnot is specifically regarding
the Empire like the fact that they have
these former Empire people as employees and
stuff and they're just like no it's been fun
not a questionable thing about Allegiance
or anything of that regard just like no
no this is just like one-offs
I think what the new Republic is missing
narratively because like there's a they're
always a drawing from history and so the
historical presidents here is like yeah
we employed an extraordinary amount of Nazis after
World War II because we were scared of the Soviets
I think the issue is there's like no they're just
like Yeah It's just tough times you know a lot
of Transitions and things and there's no you know
and here we are creating an existential potential
crisis something that contests the new Republic
something that um and just instantly they're like
ah yeah we're not gonna take one of our most
trusted generals advice like we're not gonna
um and like mon Mothman you're the chancellor like
you know I'm sure they've stripped the powers down
significantly since jar jar but like you know
uh anyway I do want to talk about The Inquisitor
for a minute if that's okay um sure because I've
been thinking endlessly about it and while my hope
narratively speaking is that it's still Barris I
do really really like the idea of Sam Whitmer who
played Maul uh and among many other characters
and also voiced Starkiller in Force Unleashed
I do love the idea of them bringing a version of
that character to live action and the reason I
love that is because for those that played
forced Unleashed Starkiller was Vader's
apprentice and I think narratively for Ahsoka
who is Anakin's Apprentice to go head to head
with somebody who was Vader's apprentice would
create such a fascinating Dynamic definitely
um and if it's Ezra I will lose my mind because
narratively that makes absolutely no sense it is
such a waste it's weird I feel like it actually
does make sense in terms of if Ezra was actually
with thrawn and was able to see because you see
the problem is this you're saying thrawn's on the
right side I'm saying the Nuance that you speak
about to thrawn is present in the books yeah
and stuff that's not present in Rebels yeah he's
very he's very much a bad guy in rep I think for
the most part he's a bad guy we're in the books
let me let me let me let me out loud yes I think
thrawn is a bad guy who does bad things I think
thrawn became a bad guy who does bad things Thanos
because he's scared of something yeah stuff like
that is a thousand percent yeah and I think like
the the nuanced complexity where one can strongly
argue that like hey he's not necessarily just a
black and white villain I feel like there is a way
he can play an influence and especially with Ezra
who has often been teased uh with the dirtiest the
dark side but alert to the dark side many times I
feel like the dark side can take hold of Ezra but
she also thinks of his friends and so so he thinks
he's doing something good I I agree on a narrative
level that when we get to the other Galaxy
that we will find in Ezra who may very well be
aligned with thrawn what I don't think is that
that Ezra somehow managed to travel back
to this galaxy didn't let his friends know
I just I don't I don't see any rational
logical explanation I just explained it
out I do saw the plan I went on the subway very
I do feel very confident though that we know
Ezra Bridger that we'd find in this other
Galaxy I think you're absolutely right in
that he'll probably be aligned with thrawn
they'll probably be working together and
that will probably be really challenging for
Sabine who's probably finally coming into her
own with the force and he's like I'm finally a
Jedi and wait the Jedi admired most in the world
um is working with the evil villain John Johnny
yes grand Admiral yawn that's my name don't
wear it out all right John what did you say
the episode I mean I have so many thoughts about
this very straightforward action-oriented episode
I mean I liked uh you know I feel like I said
almost just stay on conspiracy yeah I mean I
thought this did a nice job the the loveliest
thing this did was portray a an action-based
situation that the whole time to me anyway
did feel like a character building and a team
building exercise and I think the ideal you know
it's easy to Dazzle in fact across all of these
shows of debatable quality we've gone and seen
different dog fights and and recontextualized
versions of other action set pieces we've
seen before and I thought this did nicely
to make something that was visually gripping
and exciting but that also yeah feels like you
are watching two people mend some aspect of their
relationship or open back up to each other as well
as as you guys pointed out uh learning the new
things one that Padawan needs to learn from their
master and two that Master needs to learn from the
overall situation and from Padawan in general and
then you got yeah but who's The Inquisitor it's
Ezra Bridger I don't know no it's not John it's
the ghost of Han Solo it's not dead yet not
dead yet no but we're gonna get time travel
we do already have time travel oh yeah Ghost type
traveled back and you became The Inquisitor I was
I was pretty convinced for a minute that Balin
was just an ALT history Anakin Skywalker from a
different parallel universe for a millisecond
I was I feel like the gray Jedi aspects
of of Balin and and great character actress she's
honestly so for the fact that we don't know her
name I think she's extruded I feel like she I feel
like they are representative of to help set us
up for the when we do see Ezra Bridger that these
are these people are not just like black and white
they're Sith you know that they're not that we're
setting up a way where they are yes they use dark
side stuff but they really believe they're doing
it for a great cause yeah you know and um I am
wondering why Morgan ellsbeth though really is so
uh adamant on serving thrawn that I am wondering
if there's more because like we're opening up
the realm of magic now yeah I mean it's always
existed but you know there's always been like
this weird subsection where like we never really
explored magic in like the live action stuff and
I'm kind of wondering if that's going to be the
there's some type of battling of magic that we're
ultimately building to and I feel like there is
something linked to like that's what's it in
Marvel it's like Wizards aliens what's the the
phrase that they use and robots and robots that's
what we're that's what they're doing here uh I am
just curious of like what is that planet that
we're ever uh thrawn is on if there are others
is that where the magic comes from so that's play
into that my kind of like head Canon Theory at
this point is they have taken the time now to
say that according to the Jedi there used to be
multiple Intergalactic hyperspace Intergalactic
hyperspace hyperspace intergalactics which raises
the question um are there night sisters are there
Jedi of a different type yeah that exists in these
other galaxies and is there just a much larger
narrative at play than what we've been limited
there are people who it's like zootopia but
everyone has the force and they're just oh yeah
but that's but that's kind of the interesting
so like I mean even special who everyone has
yeah but even like you know in in talking about
like the chess and the unknown regions which is
still in this galaxy like that's drawn species
you know they have a group of force sensitive
youth who are called the Skywalker Corps and like
they help navigate through these hyperspace lanes
and the you know the difficulties of the unknown
region using the force and so but they have no
other exposure to the Jedi right and so I think
if we're exploring other galaxies where the force
still exists we will see other interpretations
of how the force manifests in different societies
yeah which I think leads perfectly into what
you're saying about like well there'll be some
interesting conversations between Magic and the
force and what that looks like you know but but
ultimately you'll find out if it's constructed in
a lap uneasy yeah it's been of course obviously
drink your Force juice boys I think it's about
Africa I think ultimately what we're we're
looking at though with this uneasy alliance
between Baylin and Morgan and Company thrawn
um Ezra and I think soon Ahsoka and
Sabine and maybe Luke maybe you know and
then jarin and Company I mean because the
other thing that we have to think about here
is that these this is what he's it's he said
we're taking all these shows and we're going
to turn them into one big cinematic story
which means this Impressions George Lucas
Dear George Lucas impression now I just I
just I thought you were doing earlier Dave
filoni is Dave filoni he's kind of like
it's like Dave filoni is a cowboy hat
it's poetry we gotta end this yeah anyway
um so that's all I have to say it's poetry not
a novel oh yo did you guys see that um there
I do have they drop some Star Wars
trailers for some video games that's
amazing yeah yeah during this episode no I can't
wait to never get around that's all right uh maybe
I'll start my own competitive YouTube channel
start reacting Star Wars Theory explained
use the mic that's the mic use
the mouse use the mic that's great
um double double meaning um hey we should uh
thank you all for being here like subscribe and
uh John good work today and also uh we should
shout out some patrons let's do that all right
guys we're improvising this let's start it
off tomorrow Alexander yes and and safirchi
Christian Neal Ryan Smith Kevin Meek Adrian
Tims oh I'm in a quarter here real knock Goss
differently same Marco tan still Lauren America
horse simply faded sj-94 Justin Martin Lucy baby
Darth yoda06 yes jay bird call it did Phil J
Smith Jr Jen Smith Melanie love freaking Blanc
you are all invited to join the Jedi Academy
all you younglings out there yeah I hope you
don't get slayed come to the temple and be with
us good job people do yes well that's the rest of
the shout outs to just be that appreciate all of
you guys thank you so much for being here yeah we
really love you I love saying your names you have
great names love you we do surrounded you or Craig
I got Greg's impressions I'm still here if I shout
bye everybody